for many of these primary school
children and their parents
it seemed like this day would never come
a school year of classes lost
of studying at home of not seeing their
friends
they're back but cautiously carefully
concerned
we've got all the necessary measures in
place alcoholic gel
disinfected mats sprays masks
thermometers
the idea is that everyone's relaxed to
let them know they can send their
children to school without being worried
that we've got everything in place to
look after them
not everyone however is likely to be
convinced the covered 19 virus has
killed 50 000 people in argentina
2 million have been infected while the
vaccination programme
has still only reached a few hundred
thousand
definitely in the next few days or when
the older pupils return to school
there will be families who are concerned
and that's fine but we all have to
understand that we've got to learn to
live with this virus
school attendance this year is
obligatory initially one-third of pupils
are returning
60 of the 180 who normally attend this
primary school
the first day back at school after the
long summer break
is always an emotional sometimes
traumatic time
especially after the year we've just had
for the children
their parents and the teachers
laura says they've lost the habit of
coming to school
that it's a routine they're all having
to re-learn
i understand they've done everything
possible although it's still not 100
secure i'd rather we'd had our vaccines
that things had been done differently
maybe more gradually or with the classes
more spaced out
she says a year had seemed like much
longer especially for her daughter lucia
i'd like to see all my friends because
it's been a year since i last saw them
i really want to see them
meanwhile the first batch of half a
million doses of the oxford astrosenica
vaccine manufactured in india
has arrived in buenos aires to bolster
supplies of the russian sputnik vaccines
already being administered
as argentina slowly tentatively
struggles to return
to the life it had before starting with
the youngest
daniel schweiner al-jazeera juan osiris